je vous cache pas qu'il y a un peu
d'émotion dans l'air car ça sera mon
dernier Télématin mais oui justement
j'allais vous en toucher un mot ça a été
un plaisir en tout cas pour moi de vous
avoir de l'autre côté de la passerelle
de vous rencontrer cette année vous
m'avez fait un compliment je vous le
rends vous êtes belle fraîche également
et je vous souhaite bonne route
c'est mon dernier 19 ans je pars pour de
nouvelles aventures toujours sur France
3 avec bientôt un magazine quotidien sur
les Jeux Olympiques j'en suis très
heureuse pendant 13 ans j'ai eu en tout
cas beaucoup de plaisir à vous retrouver
à 19h30 merci sincèrement de votre
fidélité de votre confiance aussi chaque
soir vous étiez plus de 2 millions et
demi à suivre le 19 20 alors ça fait
chaud au coeur c'était aussi une immense
responsabilité sur l'originale la jeune
femme a une pose troplassive qui
n'incarne pas l'esprit du festival de
bande dessinée selon la commune de
Dieppe alors à sa demande voici la
version retouchée la pile de livres
vient cacher le décolleté de l'héroïne
et les bretelles de son haut se sont
épaissies un choix assumer pour éviter
une nouvelle polémique après son affiche
le mois dernier à l'occasion d'une
braderie mais ça n'a pas empêché les
internautes de crier au sexisme et à la
censure ils ont riposté avec le hashtag
je kiffe mon décolleté accompagné d'une
photo un mouvement soutenu par les
femmes comme les hommes et nous avons
pensé que la représentation d'une jeune
femme en pause lassive avec un décolleté
certes léger n’entrait pas dans la
vision que nous nous faisons de la lutte
contre les discriminations
vous vous rendez compte revoyons encore
ça revoyons encore donc la jeune femme à
gauche quand nous avons vu l'affiche
nous avons alerté l'association en pose
lascive
voilà c'est gênant une trompe sur le
front comme ça c'est-à-dire que je sais
pas de quel côté la mettre
question c'est une vraie question mais
tu verras une fois que tu auras trouvé
un côté tu changeras pas ce serait plus
pratique de quel côté tu portes ils ont
analysé l'orgasme féminin qui a
longtemps été considéré comme l'un des
plus grands mystères de ce bas monde
surtout pour nous les hommes leur
conclusion est la suivante il y a trois
types d'orgasmes féminins imagés par ces
chercheurs la première c'est la vague
qui vous fait vivre apparemment de
courtes rafales de contractions
pelvienne précédée d'un rythme entrée
d'attention plus relâchement du plancher
pelvien
en fait on sait jamais couché ensemble
mais on s'est réveillé
je l'ai vu par exemple se laver les
dents dans les toilettes de France
Télévision d'ailleurs je dois vous
témoigner de son hygiène irréprochable
et ça j'ai vraiment apprécié merci
le volcan détaillé par ses chercheurs
tchèques là c'est précédé de tension
croissante du plancher pelvien tirant
vers le haut c'est la réduc périnéeale
on s'en doute et enfin et à mon avis
vous êtes de cette équipe la team
avalanche qui se traduit par des
contractions bases du plancher pelvien
de forte et maintenu tout au long d'une
stimulation bref il y a trois styles
c'est on peut avoir les trois dans une
vie où on est oui bien sûr
par semaine en direct à l'antenne c'est
une vraie vie de couple d'ailleurs
Julien m'appelle son mari de télé et
j'ai été un mari de télé comblé donc je
voulais te dire fidèle et je te remercie
parce que c'est pas le cas de tous les
maris de France juste une chose à vous
signaler c'est qu'une autre étude nous
apprend que les Françaises vous allez
surtout le risque d'être dans la team
pas d'orgasme du tout parce que de
toutes les femmes européennes ce sont
les françaises qui ont le plus de
difficultés à atteindre l'orgasme là
aussi c'est sérieux et de moins
d'orgasme par mois là aussi je vous
laisse avec cette information c'est pas
pourquoi on sait pas pourquoi on sait
que sont les hollandaises en plus voilà
c'est du sanglanté
et enfin très grand merci à Delphine
Ernotte et Stephen site bongomez qui ont
eu la bonne idée il y a deux ans de me
faire revenir sur le service public
alors que j'étais dans un excellent
centre de formation en pâtisserie à
Neuilly-sur-Seine je parle le cœur léger
et je vous laisse avec l'excellente
journaliste Marie Portolano qui a mangé
les mêmes gâteaux que moi mais ça se
voit moins sur elle 100 degrés
Fahrenheit au Texas c'est 38 degrés
Celsius suffisant pour cuire des cookies
sur un tableau de bord
8 heures de cuisson tout de même
oh mon dieu ça a fait de vrais cookies
mais la chaleur inquiète les autorités
avec le taux d'humidité très élevé les
températures ressenties peuvent dépasser
les 45 degrés à l'ombre avec un risque
réel sur la santé
double vasque oh merci
je me suis pas fait mal
pardon excusez-moi pardon
je vais essayer de ne pas trop vous
décourager
jamais les Français n'ont eu autant
envie de voyager
je veux je dois je dois être ma voiture
en route
on peut comprendre en haute saison
ma chérie
André du Pérou être ta tête depuis 73
ans songe parfois à déménager
comment est-ce que vous vous vivez le
cet afflux de touristes
ils vendent leur maison autour
en quatre le citron
en 6 la lavande
[Musique]
3 bien sûr alors là après
dans ce Mission Impossible vous parlez
français un tout petit peu mais quand
même alors qu'est-ce que vous pouvez
nous dire
s'il vous plaît quelques mots
je ne veux pas être ridicule les gens
vont se dire
j'aurais dû m'entraîner un peu pour vous
OK
[Musique]
le lion n'est pas mort ce soir Alban et
bien vivant il est vraiment
et puis je vais vous remercier vous
chers téléspectateurs de Télématin j'ai
eu la chance et l'honneur de vous
réveiller tous les matins merci de
m'avoir accepté à la table de votre
petit déjeuner on va donc se retrouver
tous les après-midi oh là là c'est une
affaire
[Musique]
et nous on se dit à très très très vite
et belle soirée à vous et je vous
embrasse
peut-être vous pouvez nous dire au
revoir en français merci beaucoup c'est
parfait merci beaucoup merci beaucoup